we choose yeah you heard it right do
something meaningful with this what do I
need to see their vote Oakland me right
then he is mr. Wu the math teacher from
cherrybrook in Sydney who's making maths
fun with his online lessons and last
night what about this he was named
Australia's local hero for 2018 Eddie Wu
joins us now congratulations my man a
big round of applause there how do you
feel
look I'm still sort of coming down from
this incredible high we all here in
Canberra had our money on all the
different amazing state and territory
recipients and I was sure I knew who was
gonna win a local hero and then when my
name was called out I just my heart
didn't skip a beat I think it skipped
three or four and I'm still I don't know
if it started up again but it's just
amazing I watched your reaction it was
beautiful it looked like your most shed
a tear obviously as you say so many
deserving winners but you got the Gong
this time round give us a little bit of
history how did this come about why did
you start posting these lessons online
five years ago I had this student of
mine who was just a year 10 16 years old
and he was diagnosed with pancreatic
cancer which I mean that's an incredibly
violent disease as most people know I
mean I think of three to six months was
a sort of typical prognosis and he was
going to spend weeks and weeks being
treated and recovering for his amis
immune system and I thought look if I
just send this boy away with a textbook
and say you know read chapter five we'll
see you in a month good luck that just
felt like such a feeble sort of response
and I mean my mum was diagnosed with
lung cancer when I was you ten I knew
what kind of transformation that would
do to a boy's life and I thought I want
him to be normal for at least one part
vidas existence and so I just got my
phone out I put it up on the table and I
thought it can take video it's a bit
sort of her key and low quality but you
can see the whiteboard you can hear my
voice I hit record and the rest is
history well done well said and look its
energy isn't it its energy and passion
so many teachers have in teaching our
kids what is the secret do you think to
learning and what is the secret for a
teacher in communicating with young
people I don't know if it's a secret but
I think that the real key to being an
effective engaging teacher is to know
that teaching is not just about
conveying information it's not about
just lecturing at people because if that
were the case people have the internet
now they do not need us education real
teaching is about having a relationship
with students being able to make a
connection with them and through that
relationship through that connection
connecting them to an idea a skill a
concept helping them understand okay hey
I can see you have this amazing talent
maybe you don't even know it yet but I
can help nurture that and help you
become something amazing that's what
teaching is really about for me and
Eddie I know you are really passionate
about making education accessible to all
children give them an education you give
them a life absolutely and it's why I
feel so strongly about putting my videos
online and making them available free I
mean technology is not a replacement for
teachers like I mentioned before you've
got to have that relationship with with
the individual who you sit next to but
what technology can do is help bridge so
many of the gaps and you know a lot of
people in the news we hear about amazing
education systems like say Finland and
Singapore but people often forget that
Singapore is just one tiny little city
and we are twenty five million people
spread across something bigger than
Europe and so those challenges of
remoteness and rural communities that
don't have the same access as something
I'm really keen to be able to address I
was taught by my maths teacher that some
people are built for maths and others
are
yeah well I would beg to disagree with
that teacher no I mean I really have to
say this quite honestly when I was at
school English and history were far and
away my best subjects I just I love
stories you know but I went into
mathematics teaching because to cut a
long story short at university I was
told the incredible need that we have
and I just wanted to be useful I wanted
to go wherever that people needed that
assistance and what I came to realize
was even as someone who just loves
writing stories loves reading about you
know battles and politics and all that
kind of thing actually mathematics
really is for everyone if I can sort of
grab a hold of it I think anyone really
can maybe your passion is just
infectious and I reckon you would have
fired up a lot of people out there to
perhaps consider teaching as a career
and for those already there you've given
them an extra boost congratulations and
good luck with the year ahead you're
wonderful thank you so much it's lovely
talking to you here well said Georgie I
should say he's already got 200,000
subscribers and millions worldwide who
are tuning into word tube isn't he
fabulous this makes me want to go back
to maths